字幕: YORIKO NODA
校正: Yuri Ueda
（ヒメナ･エレゲダ）（スペイン語）
こんにちは　お元気ですか？
（スティーブン･ウォード）
（英語）こんにちは
（スティーブン）
２人のライフワークの始まりは 22年前
ここ 日本からでした
お互いの作品に 関わりを持ち
次第に 共同制作を始めます
（ヒメナ） そして 野外で
誰でも自由に触れられる—
焼き物の作品を
作るようになりました
それは まるで 船を造りながら
海を渡っていく
冒険のようでした
（スティーブン）20年前の夏
市の許可を得て
１か月かけて 公共の場に粘土で
これぐらいの形を作り
廃材を使って焼きました
製作中 ２度の台風に耐え
完成した作品は
「空の広場」と名付けました
しかし ある日
この作品は 壊されてしまいました
（ヒメナ）作品を形作っていた
３トンの粘土は
瓦礫になってしまったのです
あまりのショックに
私は子どもをおぶって
市役所の担当者まで
作品の破片を持っていきました
納得できる説明はなかったのですが
壊された原因のひとつは
場所と人の関係を
考えなかったからだと気付きました
そこで 実際に地域の人と
コミュニケーションを取りつつ
一緒に制作をすることで
そこでしか生み出すことの
できないものを
創りたいと思いました
（スティーブン）
この町に作品を残したいという
２人の強い思いが届き
再び 公共の公園で
制作する許可をもらいました
（ヒメナ）次の作品のテーマは
人と人が向き合える場
場所 人 作品の３つを
つなぎ合わせるビジョンです
（スティーブン）
この作品は 公園で制作していたので
いろいろな人が声をかけてくれました
一緒に粘土やレンガを運び
窯焚きも力を合わせたことで
作品と人の繋がりができました
３年間つくった作品は
その場所で焼き
熱や圧力で岩のようになり
ずっとその場所に残り続けます
「空と曙の広場」です
私たちが なぜこのような
空間を作ろうと思ったのか
（ヒメナ）ベネズエラにある
石で作られた野外劇場で感じた—
さまざまな音の響き
（スティーブン）
アメリカの大木の空洞で経験したー
包み込まれるような感覚から
インスピレーションを得たからです
（ヒメナ）音に包まれる不思議な空間を
粘土で表現したくなりました
そのインスピレーションに
鵜や鷹の群れが飛ぶ—
田んぼに囲まれた里山が繋がりました
遊び ダンス 音楽
劇と自然が一緒になって
新しい表現が生まれる場所
焼き物の反響板を持つ野外劇場
それが 「山の広場 野外劇場」です
（スティーブン）焼き物の歴史は古く
26,000年も前から続いています
しかし 今回私たちが 挑戦するような
巨大な焼き物の前例が ありません
ビジョンがクリアになるにつれ
自分たちの能力や
素材の限界に迫ることは
構造上も経済的にも 大きなリスクです
（ヒメナ）私たちはリスクを承知で
代々 窯を作ってきた陶芸家
建築家 測量士
そして 歯医者さんからも
教わりながら 制作に取り掛かりました
（スティーブン）作業をしている所で
（ヒメナ）「そこで何してるんですか？
反響板 粘土で！
わあ すごいですね
大変そうですね
いつ完成するんですか？」
（スティーブン）
「まあ 今日明日には終わらないな
けど 一緒にやれば早く終わりますよ」
こういう時のために
軍手はいつも用意してありました
（笑）
（ヒメナ）「サンキュー」
少しずつ一緒に作業する人が増えていき
自分たちのビジョンが
より現実になってきました
（スティーブン）（英語）来れる時に
（英語）出来ることを
来れる時に 出来ることを
バケツリレーで粘土を運んでる人
（ヒメナ）粘土をこねてる人
（スティーブン）おにぎりつくってる人
（ヒメナ）
何もしないでずっと喋ってる人
（スティーブン）大きな葉っぱを傘にして
走り回ってる子どもたち
（ヒメナ）すでに劇が始まってます
多くの人が参加する中で
出会いや別れ 時には対立もありました
ある時 台風で 30トン
積み上げていた反響板から
７トンが崩れる出来事がありました
より早く直そうと
工場のラインのようなやり方を
押しつけてきた人がいましたが
多くの人は機械的な作業に反対でした
（スティーブン）何故なら 土と関わり
その場でしか出来ない時間を
体験するために
参加したい人が多かったからです
ただ早くできればいい と考えている人は
ほとんどいませんでした
（ヒメナ）ようやく窯を作る段階
ひとつ 28キロのレンガを
積み重ねて窯を作ります
５メートルの高さまで熱が
逃げないように 組み上げていきます
それはまさに 200トンのパズルです
ここまで来るのに すでに
周りの田んぼの稲刈りを
14回も見てしまいました
終わりが見えない 延々と続く労働の中
ビジョンを失ってしまいそうでした
同時に この時期は
仲間が あまり集まりませんでした
休みの日に レンガ運びたい人って
いないでしょ?
（笑）
（スティーブン） あれ？
（ヒメナ）あ！ いるかもしれない
いるかな？
（笑）
それでもまた覗きに来る人もいました
（スティーブン）
「まだ終わってないの？」
（ヒメナ）「軍手ならありますよ」
（スティーブン）「お！ サンキュー」
（笑）
（ヒメナ）こうして いよいよ
窯が完成しました
粘土は 高い温度で焼かれると 石になり
二度と土へは戻りません
この反響板を焼き固めるには
40日かけて 1,200度上がるまで
焼き続ける必要がありました
窯焚きは一発勝負
失敗は許されません
もしも 焼いている途中で爆発したら？
うまく温度が上がらなかったら？
今までビジョンを共にしてきた人たち
そして 自分たちが費やした
資金や時間を考えると
不安で落ち着きませんでした
（スティーブン）
40日間の窯焚きはマラソンです
火を入れて 最初は
音楽で言う「モデラート」
低温をじっくりキープします
そして 窯の温度はだんだん
アレグロのように速く上げていき
最後には全力で熱し上げます
キャンプ生活しながら
無心に焚き続けました
連日の寝不足で — ふぅ！
みんな 頭がおかしくなりそう
というか 実際におかしくなりました
（笑）
（ヒメナ）そして最後に
一本の赤松を投げ入れ 窯焚きは終了
本当に上手く焼けているかどうかは
さらに冷めるまで
40日間 待たなければなりません
２年の試作 ３年の反響板 10年の窯
そして １年をかけて窯を解体すると
蛹から蝶が羽ばたくように
オカリナのような反響板が
姿を現しました
（スティーブン）
「山の広場 野外劇場」は当初
完成には２年を予定していましたが
結局16年もかかってしまいました
時には 想定外だからこそ
達成できることもあります
（ヒメナ）このプロジェクトに関わった
のべ2,000人もの人びと
それぞれが 自分なりに劇場の
イメージを持ってたでしょう
しかし ビジョンは
単なるイメージとは違います
ビジョンは未来を創る力です
その力で ３つの可能性をつなぎ合わせ
このプロジェクトは実現しました
（スティーブン）
場所の可能性 そこだから出来る
（ヒメナ）人の可能性
誰にでも出来ることがある
（スティーブン）時間の可能性
時間をかければ出来る
この里山に人が集まり 劇場が完成し
新しい表現が生まれることで
生きた場所に生まれ変わりました
それは 私たちが目指したビジョン
そのものでした
（ヒメナ）（英語）人のために
人が創った場所
人のために 人が創った場所
（音楽）
（音楽終わり）
（ヒメナ） この巨大な反響板は
空から見ると 小石のようにしか 映りません
しかし その小石に 造った
みんなの手の跡が確かに残り
この経験を通して生まれた
一人ひとりの思いが
これからも新たな物語を
紡ぎ出していくでしょう
みなさんも 自分の持っている
ビジョンに向かって
自分の船をひとりで漕ぐもよし
（スティーブン）
みんなで協力して漕ぐもよし
（ヒメナ） さあ 新たな物語を
（ヒメナ&スティーブン）
創る冒険を始めましょう！
（ヒメナ）（英語）ありがとうございます
（スティーブン）（スペイン語）ありがとう
（拍手）